[Music]
free at last it's a sentiment shared by
millions of chileans after 18 months of
a state of emergency imposed by the
government because of the pandemic
a non-interrupted curfew one of the
world's longest forced people to rush
home early every day now chileans are
hoping to get back to a semi-normal life
[Music]
discotheques and bars will also finally
be able to reopen until the wee hours of
the morning
we're very happy this is good for the
economy and for people's state of mind
it's been too long
it was about time now we can finally go
out at night and have a social life that
we really needed
so far there have been more than 3 700
coronavirus related deaths in chile and
some 1.6 million confirmed cases
health officials and politicians concede
that the long-running curfew had become
unnecessary but truth be told it was
becoming almost impossible to enforce
yet not everyone is happy about the
restrictions being lifted
my friends are going to want to kill me
but i wish we still had the curfew i
could tell guests that it was time to
leave or i could leave early by just
saying oops it's almost curfew time to
go
although there's no longer a curfew
plenty of restrictions still remain
19 infections have dropped dramatically
in chile more than 90 percent of the
target population has been fully
vaccinated and some people have even
received a third dose but as you can see
you still have to wear a face mask
everywhere except while eating and you
also have to show proof of vaccination
to enter most places
chile's borders are now also finally
open to international travelers a
lifesaver for the crippled tourist
industry but anyone who enters the
country must go into quarantine for five
to seven days
it's a glass at least half full
unfortunately these newfound freedoms
could disappear if infection rates begin
to surge once again
lucia newman al jazeera santiago